In the last lecture we talked about
consideration and how courts look for a
bargain for exchange to determine
whether a promise creates an enforceable
contract.
Today we're going to introduce another
basis for enforcing promises known as
promissory Estoppel.
The doctrine of promissory Estoppel
has its roots in the 1898 Nebraska case
called rickets versus Ska Thorn in
which there was no bargain for exchange,
but the courts found a legally
enforceable promise. Anyway,
the facts are these. The plaintiff in
the Ricketts case, Katie Scott Thorn,
received a written promise
from our grandfather,
John c records that he would pay her
quote on demand $2,000 to be at 6% per
annum.
When he made the promise,
the grandfather told Ms Ska Thorn,
that quote,
I have fixed out something that you
have not got to work anymore unquote,
and that none of my grandchildren
work and you don't have to.
A year later with the consent and
assistance of her grandfather,
she got a new job.
Two years later,
the grandfather died having paid one
year's interest on the note and having
expressed regret that he had not
been able to pay the balance.
Ms Cawthorne then sued the executor
of the grandfather's estate,
Andrew Directorates for the balance.
So was there consideration in this case?
No,
not in this case.
The grandfather promised to give
his granddaughter the money,
but uh,
he did not ask for anything in return,
nor did she promise anything in return.
Although she quit her job after he
implied that she would not need to work
anymore or grandfather did not condition
the money on her quitting her job.
In the words of the court,
the plaintiff's grandfather gave her
the note as a gratuity and asked for
nothing in return.
And the abandonment by Miss Goth orn
ever position as a bookkeeper was all
together voluntary.
Therefore,
the note was not given in consideration
of the plaintiff pursuing or green to
pursue any particular line of conduct.
The trial court found for the plaintiff
and the instant court affirmed not
withstanding the lack of of consideration.
So the central issue on appeal is this,
despite the lack of consideration,
is the grandfather's promise
still legally enforceable?
As we just discussed, the court found
there was no consideration in this case.
Therefore, if consideration is absolutely
necessary for a binding promise,
the grandfather's promise
would not be legally. However,
there have always been traces of an
easiness respecting a strong consideration
requirement.
Much of the dissatisfaction relates to
transactions such as those involved in
rickets where a promise
induces substantial and
bargained for reliance on the
part of the promise.
See,
do you think it would be fair if the
grandfather or in this case his estate
could later fail to perform his promise
after his granddaughter relied on that
promise and quit her job,
the court didn't think it would be fair.
The court reason that the grandfather
intentionally influenced the plaintiff to
alter her position for the worst on the
faith of the note being paid when due so
it would be grossly inequitable to permit
the maker or his executor to resist
payment on the ground that the promise
was given without consideration to get
around the consideration requirement,
the court invoke the doctrine
of equitable Estoppel.
The court can see did that the promise
quote being given without any valuable
consideration was nothing more than a
promise to make a gift in the future and
that ordinarily such promises
are not enforceable. However,
the court held that a promise
or who promises to make a gift,
maybe a stopped that is stopped or
barred from denying the existence of the
consideration if the promise see
changes her position in reliance on the
promise.
In other words,
even though the grandfather's promise to
his granddaughter was not supported by
consideration,
the executor of the estate was estopped
from arguing that the promise lacked
consideration because,
uh,
his granddaughter had quit her
job in reliance on that promise.
The court supported it's
positioned with precedent pass.
Courts had held that quote,
an action on a note given to a church
college or other like institution upon the
faith of which money has been expended
or obligations incurred could not be
successfully defended on the
ground of a want of consideration.
But those courts found an enforceable
promise for a different reason.
Those courts held that quote.
The expenditure of money or assumption
of liability by the Doni on the faith of
the promise constitutes a valuable
and sufficient consideration.
The court in Ricketts on the other hand
held that there was no consideration but
it stopped the defendant
from raising that defense.
This use of Estoppel was
unusual for two reasons. First,
equitable equitable estoppel traditionally
only applied to representations of
facts. If you represent it to a
patient that you are a specialist,
you can be estopped from later denying
it in court even if you in fact are not a
specialist.
Second,
the doctrine of equitable Estoppel is
commonly understood to provide a shield,
not a sword. Estoppel is a
defense that prevents another, uh,
from denying certain facts.
In rickets.
The doctrine is applied as a sword to
support a new cause of action that would
otherwise not exist.
Was the Ricketts courts simply confused
about the meaning of equitable Estoppel?
Well,
one might instead read the opinion
as a good example of judicial craft.
Under the common law,
the court observed a form of injustice.
It the court observed a form of injustice
that the law might remedy finding no
clear legal grounds at hand
and facing the bar, uh,
of the, uh, against enforcement
under the doctrine of consideration.
It took a neighboring legal category,
Estoppel and stretched
it a bit to do new work.
This is the process of
creative destruction where
courts sometimes do injury to
an existing concept to help
redeploy it in another context.
It's only later that courts
feel comfortable giving.
The new creation is separate and new name.
The modern term promissory Estoppel dates
from Samuel [inaudible] 1920 previous
on contract law will Astin carefully
studied cases and convinced himself that
the consideration doctrine could not
explain all the case see outcomes and his
treatise.
Wilson collected a number
of cases including rickets
in which reliance seem to
be doing the job of consideration.
It was a substitute for consideration
recognizing the differences between the
well established doctrine of equitable
stopple and the doctrine invoked by this
collection of cases.
Wilson suggested a new name for the
ladder promissory Estoppel Wilston later
served as the reporter on the first
restatement of contracts and included a
section,
a new section,
section 94 promissory Estoppel.
The sections number remained the
same in the second restatement,
which now reads a promise
which the promissor should
reasonably expect to induce
action or forbearance on the part of
the primacy or a third person and which
does induce such action or forbearance
is binding if injustice can be avoided
only by enforcement of the promise.
The remedy granted for breach may be
limited as justice requires section 90 is
one of the few sections of the restatement
that you should commit to memory as
synonymous with promissory Estoppel.
You can see that it has three elements,
the promise or should have her
promise to induce reliance.
The promise must actually
and must actually induce
reliance and injustice can be
avoided only by the promises enforcement.
If the plaintiff in rickets versus Scott
Thorn had not quit her job after her
grandfather promised her $2,000 plus
interest with the promise had been binding
under the theory of promissory Estoppel.
Nope.
If Miss Goth Thorn did not rely
on the promise to her detriment,
she would not satisfy one
of the requirements for
promissory Estoppel so the
promise would not be
binding under that doctrine.
The court awarded Miss Goth or in the
$2,000 face amount of the promissory note
plus interest.
This put Ms. Scott Orn in the position
she would have been in if the promise had
been performed.
When a court does this,
we say that the court awards expectation
damages cause the court puts the
plaintiff in the position she would
expect to be in when the promise was made.
But section 90 permits courts to limit
the remedy has justice requires relying
on her grandfather's promise.
Ms. Scott Thorn quit her job,
which paid $10 a week for a
year before taking another job.
In other words,
she sacrificed at most $520
when she relied on the promise.
Therefore,
wouldn't justice be served if damages
were limited to $520 if the court did so,
we would say that the court
awarded reliance damages,
reliance damages seek to make the promise
the whole by compensating her for the
cost she incurred in relying
on the promise instead of
putting the promising and
the position she would have been in
had the promise been fully performed.
Grant Gilmore famously predicted in
a book called death of contracts that
section 90 would swallow contracts
pro that promises would use promissory
Estoppel claims under section 90 instead
of breach of contract claims to enforce
their promises. But Gilmore's
prediction has not come true.
Promises routinely opt to sue for breach
of contract because it's a more certain
basis for liability.
Avoiding all these considerations
of what justice requires and without
potentially having limited damages.
So let's recap.
Sometimes consideration is not
needed to enforce a promise.
If a promise he reasonably relies on
a promise and changes are positioned
accordingly, the promise may be
binding even without consideration.
If justice so requires,
however,
the remedy granted for the breach may
be limited to compensate the primacy for
her reliance and the court need not
award the full value of the promise.